Tucker Carlson
is back
hey it's Tucker Carlson the offender
people say the news is full of lies but
most of the time that's not exactly
right much of what you see on television
or read the New York Times is in fact
true in the literal sense it could pass
one of the media's own fact checks
lawyers would be willing to sign off on
it in fact they may have but that
doesn't make it true it's not true at
the most basic level the news you
consume is a lie a lie of the
stealthiest and most Insidious kind
facts have been withheld on purpose
along with proportion and perspective
you are being manipulated amazingly as
of tonight there aren't many platforms
left that allow Free Speech the last big
one remaining in the world the only one
is Twitter where we are now starting
soon we'll be bringing a new version of
the show we've been doing for the last
six and a half years to Twitter
we bring some other things to which
we'll tell you about but for now we're
just grateful to be here free speech is
the main right that you have without it
you have no others see you soon
so the context here is not just that
okay Tucker is going to start streaming
on Twitter the context is that Tucker is
going to break his contract with Fox
News Fox took him off the air Fox didn't
exactly fire him he's still being paid
millions and millions and millions of
dollars reports are that he is still
owed out about 26 million dollars on his
Fox contract which he's willing to break
to go on and bring you
the news and the reports that you're not
seeing on other shows on the one
platform that will allow you to do it
that would be Twitter
talked yesterday about the the plan of
the liberal establishment to shut this
guy up it's not just Fox News it's the
advertisers it's all of these
colluding forces who really want to shut
Tucker up
because Tucker gave a different
perspective not just different from the
left but different from many people on
the right that's why the libs focused on
him so much so the question we asked
yesterday was does this mean Tucker is
just going to be silenced through 2024
and I don't know maybe he listened to
the show because he gave the answer like
five or six hours later he said we will
not be silenced
we're coming back we're going to be here
on Twitter this is big news not just not
just because Tucker's voice is
extraordinarily important in public
discourse but it's
it's important because this could end
cable news
I don't think that's hyperbolic at all
Tucker was the biggest name in cable
news not just on Fox but all of cable
news not just now but ever he's the most
popular Cable News host ever in the
history of the media
so if Tucker switches his platform
he could bring a huge audience now
that in itself wouldn't necessarily Doom
the medium of Fox News except for this
Tucker's audience is largely Boomers the
cable news audience is largely Boomers
and the reason that cable news still
exists today is because Boomers don't
want to turn the channel and they don't
want to have to pull up their Roku or
their Apple TV or their computer or
their phone or their iPad or any
anything like that no knock-on Boomers I
know there are a lot of technologically
advanced Boomers I'm a Luddite
Millennial so I'm really not casting any
stones but it is just a fact
the reason that cable news still exists
is these Boomers
almost uniquely at this point pay for
their cable subscription they leave the
TV on during the day so the nine o'clock
hour picks up all the people from the
eight o'clock hour who didn't want to
click the button on the remote and the
10 o'clock hour picks up the people from
the nine o'clock hour so if Tucker can
convince his largely Boomer audience
to switch over to Twitter
Tucker's Millennial and Zoomer audience
was already watching his Clips on
Twitter primarily if you can get the
Boomers to switch over there that could
spell the end of cable news the the day
after Tucker's firing was announced or I
guess the very same day because it was
on a Monday
the ratings in that hour were chopped in
half
and the ratings for the other Primetime
shows on Fox were chopped down in a
quarter if Tucker can actually just
remove that audience permanently
I could spell the end of cable news
certainly the end of the dominance of
cable news media don't last forever
media forms have errors okay and
cable news has has been a dominant form
for about 30 years now doesn't mean
it'll completely go away some people
still watch it but it might go the way
of radio
might go the way of
Network TV it might go the way it might
just
we just might move on now and Tucker
could if his new show works we have
every reason to think it would
that could be a huge shift not just in
the politics of the country but even in
the way that that politics has
undertaken and information is consumed
and transmitted right now head on over
to hallow.com Knowles building a habit
of prayer can help you cultivate an
attitude of gratitude focusing on what
you are thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S it's
helped countless people maintain a daily
prayer routine and it can help you too
download the app for free at hallow.com
Knowles you can set prayer reminders and
track your progress along the way not
sure where to start check out father
Mike schmitz's Bible in a year available
on the Hello app for brief daily
readings and Reflections or pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim Caviezel and
even some world-class athletes using
hallow to connect with others who share
your beliefs and values can provide a
sense of belonging support and Foster a
sense of community with hallow you can
customize a personal prayer plan that
works for you listen wherever you are
with downloadable off line sessions
download Hello at hello.com
get an exclusive three months for free
that is three months absolutely free at
hallow.com Knowles right now go to
puretalk.com Knowles you remember the
last time you got a free phone what
happened you started out feeling great
and then came the Hefty activation fees
and the four line requirements and of
course the binding contract Pure Talk is
giving you a free 5G Samsung Galaxy
phone without the feeling that you've
been duped when you switch to Pure talks
unlimited talk and text data plan that
comes with a mobile hotspot you will get
a 5G Samsung Galaxy for free that is
right unlimited everything in a fraction
of the price of Verizon ATT or T-Mobile
here's another thing you will be on
America's Most Dependable 5G network not
just a similar Network you will be on
that Network how do I know that I'm a
customer of pure talk so make the switch
be like me use puretalk the cell phone
Wireless company I am proud to stand
behind because they are proud to stand
behind our mission at the daily wire
pure talks Us customer service team
helped me to make the switch in as
little as 10 minutes I was even able to
keep my own phone number just go to
puretalk.com
for your free Samsung Galaxy when you
sign up for unlimited talk text and
unlimited data puretalk.com Knowles Pure
Talk Wireless for Americans buy
Americans speaking of Journalism
we have a looming indictment potentially
of Hunter Biden I haven't covered it
very much because I assume that the
liberal establishment is going to figure
out some way to let this guy off the
hook it's the president's son he's been
engaging in very clear public corruption
for a very long time they haven't done
anything about it sometimes I fear that
they try to make Hunter Biden a
distraction so they don't need to deal
with serious issues like The Invasion on
our Southern border right now or the
looming Prospect of World War III which
in neither party seems to be doing very
much about certainly not the Democrats
so I haven't focused on it too much but
we might get an indictment of Hunter
Biden and so preemptively the White
House has banned the New York Post from
attending President Biden's only daytime
public event on Monday as the federal
prosecutors near a decision on charging
Hunter for tax fraud and other crimes
why did they do this because the New
York Post broke the hunter Biden laptop
Story the liberal establishment went
into overdrive to shut down that story
including the government the government
pressured the big tech companies that
control the flow of information around
the Public Square said don't let this
thing go out oh it's Russian
disinformation blah blah blah
Joe Biden himself called the New York
Post story Russian disinformation
and now the New York Post is totally
Vindicated we know it wasn't
disinformation we know it was just true
information
so Joe Biden who can't answer a question
even from a friendly reporter doesn't
want to get a hostile question from the
New York Post so they banned the post
from the press conference what needs to
happen now is if Hunter Biden actually
is indicted we need the New York Post
reporters maybe the editor of the post
to show up to whatever news conference
that is like Andrew Breitbart at the
admission of guilt by representative
Anthony Weiner a lot of people may have
forgotten this incident Anthony Weiner
texted out a picture of his uh well you
know you get it from the name he so he
tweeted that that out publicly he
intended to DM it privately to someone
on Twitter Breitbart caught this he said
hey look Weiner's gotten this huge
Scandal and everyone said oh it's
disinformation it was a hacking how dare
Breitbart it's terrible it's awful and
then coincidentally Breitbart happened
to be in New York when Anthony Weiner
was holding his press conference to say
yeah okay I did it sorry Whoopsie Daisy
and then Breitbart just took the stage
and he spiked that football and he said
I was right and you guys are all
completely corrupt and I'm the only
journalist in this room that's what the
New York Post has to do on the hunter
Biden laptop story The Hunter Biden
laptop story suppression may have thrown
the 2020 election to Joe Biden made it
much much easier for Joe Biden to claim
victory they were after that election 12
percent of Biden voters according to one
poll said they would not have voted for
Biden had they known about the story
so this was a concerted effort to rig
the election for Joe Biden it may have
succeeded we need the post to be doing
the silliest end time dance end zone
dance we're living in the end times
perhaps but they need to do the end of
zone dance that you have ever seen boy
that was sizzling hunt
make sure you subscribe over here with
Michael Knowles YouTube channel click
that bell ring that thing do that doodad
and we will see you next time